[Music]
today's question comes from whitney in
missouri
i'm a saver and my husband is a spender
we set up a budget when we got married
and included an allowance for each of us
to help monitor our spending he has been
reluctant and not a good follower of our
budget is having this allowance
something that you suggest if so how
much we allot for our personal spending
and how do i fix
the issue of my husband going over the
set amount
oh man um
well a couple things whitney that stood
out in your question
we set a budget when we got married so
it's not like we said it last month so
i'm curious how long the discussion has
been how long you guys have been married
because the incur my encouragement would
be that you guys talk about it every
month
and
the allowance is it a good idea
yeah the word allowance is always weird
for me but i always say to have a
personal line item in your budget so for
our family for instance there's a rachel
line item there's a winston line item
actually our kids even have their own
line items now so i just know okay when
we're spending it like this is this is
where it's coming out of
um
and that amount is going to depend on
your income and where you guys are in
the baby steps so
uh
how do i fix basically how do i fix my
husband well whitney you don't fix your
husband i'm sorry that doesn't it's not
how it works
uh you do have to
talk to him not preach at him but
come at these conversations in a way
that you can express what is going on in
you
whether it's frustration whether you're
scared whether you don't know what to do
whether it's you long for him to be more
involved i mean expressing these needs
in a way that is not um
putting him down right like i feel like
some
savers
which contend can be more of the nerds
in the relationship
can get very legalistic and it's this
way this way this way here's how much
money you have and when you do that to
your husband like the dynamic changes it
kind of goes from this like
marriage to
a mom to her son or something like it
gets weird so
um yeah like your language is that way
not yours rachel the person in uh giving
him an allowance yeah whitney this
sounds like you're his mother yeah you
were to this not his not his wife
and so like he won't stick to his
allowance it's like oh my god what is
wrong so here's the thing you need to
sit down again and the two of you need
to decide what you want your future to
look like and what you're willing to do
to get to that future
instead of he needs to stick to his
allowance
he's a dadgum grown man he should stick
to his own allowance
because he wants to hit the goals that
he's agreed to
square your shoulders bubba man up here
okay that's not your mama this is your
wife and you're supposed to be part of
this team pulling the harness and so you
guys need to look out there in the
future together hold hands and go
there's where we want to go and here's
the price we're going to pay to get to
where we want to go and we both want to
get there so we're both going to pay
that price and that includes i'm going
to limit my personal spending to this
and you're going to limit your personal
spending to that and that's what we're
in agreement to not i'm going to be
you know schooling you up every time you
misbehave so the bottom line is i don't
think we did a budget i think you did a
budget and told him what it was
that's what it sounds like yeah yeah
and so i think he needs to get his butt
in gear and emotionally plug into
co-leading
this household
this is your wife's son it's not your
mama
and so man up
and take take take your share of the
responsibility and lady quit babying him
he's not your little boy
and that's the kind of thing that we're
talking about here now that's language
that people don't like in today's world
well go listen to another radio show
then because that's the way this really
this crap really works i've done this
for 30 years and so um
you know you guys can sit down there
together love each other love your
future
say gosh i'll do anything in the world
for you except stick to my allowance see
that that's the problem is the word
means that you allowed him to have a
certain amount of money and he didn't
stick to it right well ain't your job to
allow him
it's our job to decide what we are going
to do yeah that's the point that's the
way this stuff the the language in this
reveals it all yes and what happens so
many times in marriage when it comes to
money is the spouse becomes the enemy
right it's like well he he or she won't
oh and yeah there's issues there and in
a tactical way that if they are just
going and spending tons of money and
trying to get out i get that but instead
of seeing your spouse as the enemy look
at the things that are not being done or
look at the debt like like have things
out there that are the issue and you
guys lock arms together and look at the
problem your spouse isn't the problem um
yeah and you know you do a great job of
teaching about this on the budgeting
stuff in financial peace university this
idea that
and i forget the you do better with the
language than i do because i'm just kind
of mean about it but this this idea that
that um
both of you have to step up
and this i there
a lot of people had model had parents
modeling for you and you took that model
and it was a bad model
and they they didn't mean to they
weren't they weren't bad people but um
you know dad just worked and he never
looked at the money and mama handled all
the details
and mama paid the bills and so dad was
emotionally when it came to the
operation of the household yeah
subservient to his wife yeah or mom is
like well i don't know my husband takes
care of me i don't know what i mean and
she's over here and she's deficit and is
emotionally not plugged in and it's not
being a fully developed grown-up
in the situation both of you have to be
fully developed emotional mature
grown-ups
pulling together for the same goal when
we see that we see people change their
lives absolutely that's that's it that's
well said because both extremes
are not good you're not going to get it
on both extremes but this is not a
mansplaining thing no and it's not a
momsplaining thing no no it's not
trashing your parents thing it's none of
that there's no there's no victim or
entitlement stuff in here it's simply
you are not listen i'm not good with
money i just i let my wife handle it
she's so much smarter than me you're not
doing her a favor
you're not a blessing to her
and you even though you paid her a big
compliment she wishes she didn't have
all the weight of the decision making on
her shoulders
well my husband's really good with this
stuff his name is dave ramsey he knows
he tells everybody in america how to
handle money so i don't have to handle
money those words never left sharon
ramsay's mouth
she wants her vote to count she wants
her voice to be heard and and not in a
nagging way no but she is not
just take care of me i'm a little
southern belle and you just take it
she's not that woman yeah and because
she's like a full-grown mature woman you
know i mean oh my gosh this is what
we're talking about here both of you
step into this thing and then you'll go
win